you you're a bourbon guy more of a
bourbon guy that scotch guy my father my
father's a scotch guy as he got older
and he loved it's brown I swallowed down
yep
my father was sitting there with this
thing in a head of high-end scotch and
he said this is life it's like 7-fiver
no it's great though because he's just
lucky it arrived well licked it he said
to me he said my father said to me he
said you know I'm done like I said my
kids are doing great I've done
everything I've wanted to do he goes I'm
done he just sat down cuz I think you
know you should do some exercises should
I check a workout and stretch
I'm done if I did it yeah you're good
yeah you're good man hey he has a deep
and my mother too they have they have
deep tell ya a dissatisfaction
yeah the welder when they're older you
know do you know all right all right
hey how about it's cute Friday
apparently you didn't get the memo why
I'm adorable moody Friday look it might
look at my little you were this what do
you call these days I do every day I
don't have any closed eye I went I went
Spartan and I threw everything name
things I throw everything away I realize
I'm a t-shirt and Jean guy and anything
else is an effort anything with a collar
I'm like oh my goodness let's like what
do they call these oh it's like okay
it's a Henley day Henley doing a
three-button know what to Henley it sits
on my shoulders I carry it I carry it on
my shoulders beautiful skinny thinking
okay I'm not skinny I'm athletic it's
it's it's cute Friday it's cutie Friday
look at the way I dress it's cutie
Friday yeah you didn't get the memo
that's look you have a nice pressed
shirt on I'll give you that you do have
nice clothes oh dude you would have been
so upset today
why Pappas on the trail like you always
this yeah I'm tariff rate back in my
home turf drove to San Diego yesterday
that's my home turf going and I'm I mean
I'm 20 miles out from my house so it's I
mean it's rattlesnake territory yeah and
I might I listen to music live ride my
bike and I see a couple on horses up on
horses right big horses yeah and I was
like I kept my attention and I can see
she's going like this at me yelling yeah
and I'm like oh maybe they need help or
maybe there
there's a giant rattlesnake up things so
you'll excuse me and this lady goes
where the [ __ ] is your mask where the
[ __ ] is your [ __ ] mask pry and pry
out art about my age almost at our age I
did my dome I'm sorry my they're both
both about my age maybe a little younger
she was where the [ __ ] your math where
the [ __ ] is your Matt yo excuse me
she goes where the [ __ ] is your math
you're risking everybody out here I go
who's out here who's out here she was
weird your master yo why in the world
I'm trying not to cast that situation I
go why in the world would I wear a mask
out here are you after your goddamn mine
yelling at me she was well where's your
[ __ ] Matthew who are you talking to
saying where's your [ __ ] [ __ ] mask
and then and then I'm like you got how
would I beat the [ __ ] bond will hold
on
the hold on and their boyfriend goes
yeah dude it's not cool I like what you
say it's not cool
what's not cool and now they don't have
masks on they have bandanas on and I go
oh you dum-dums think the bandanas help
you you think about dancing and as I say
this the board upstairs go let's do a
breeze so we can see how stupid they are
breeze comes the things blow up by y'all
oh wow I can see your entire face I see
your entire face you think that's
helping I see you know you guys should
do you should wait because there's I
pass a few uh bike lists on the way you
should none of them are wearing masks
because we're not morons so when they
come you guys should ruin your whole day
and wait here like it's your job because
nobody's paying you the taxpayers aren't
paying to do this
you guys should wait here and then yell
at the other guys coming and as theirs
tell me some the two guys throw ice
baths in I was talking when we get to
the top they come by and she goes when
where's your mask and they just start
laughing and keep writing by I said I
should have done that but I I thought
you were I thought you were worn by a
snake and I stopped and spinkle complete
waste of my time and then the boyfriend
says something goes yeah well we're on
here tomorrow you better wear a mask I
was like holy [ __ ] I mean you're serious
dude you better wear masks are yo dude
I'm on this trail every day I'll be back
here tomorrow 9 a.m. I might
[ __ ] naked just approval point I go
and how about where's the mask for your
horses you know uh oh you don't care
about animals oh my god you know you
know your horse can get it she was not
[ __ ] care that's the stupid thing
haha you didn't know horses can get it
and they can have you looked it up horse
they can get it bring that up Jay like
ah you don't know who are skiing you
like all all and I go Papa you guys
watch CNN you watch and see em you're
scared straight this is the first time
leaving the house this first time
leaving the house you guys have no idea
nobody where Mastiffs are you [ __ ]
morons now you got my bike and rode off
that's great
how about the guy goes you better have a
mask on tomorrow you better have a mask
on Allah wow that's that would cause a
big problem for me and your outside
oh dude on in um I'm on to paint
mountains I'm over the hill where it's
like there's nothing yeah I'm not gonna
wear masks in here this this whole thing
is divided people what do which creates
me I could tell the the boyfriend it
wasn't such a [ __ ] was down to fight
over it he was down to fight I could
tell they would escalate there what do
you want you better have masks on what
ah you know decent-sized guy just went
ah you're serious well dude I'll be I'm
here every day
I'll be here Martin I want I'll be
endlessly please I know my please choke
my conscience and spank him for me I
know if he if he comes out you please
double leg him and then just just tie
him up just put your legs and they're
just they're just palisade rich kids
first night by the house riding daddy's
horses also oh it's also he's never been
perfect I'd say at Birkenstocks on hey
you're on the trails real riders when
we're bringing it first time on the
house alright first on the house and
then you don't care about your animals
and that set them on fire when I said
you don't care about the animals come on
fire
well you didn't know horses can get it
there's been a case of me I don't if you
died but a horse get contract open 19 oh
you don't care about your horses I see
stress man you know horses eyes are like
looking in for her when he's stressed
man he's all thoughts all the [ __ ] huge
horses oh yeah that's horses her horses
better be able to fight man well I found
this article
horses can spread it to each other just
slap it on the ass and the horses yeah
you got a little fight I steal their
horse up yeah
just pull them off it's like getting
back in those Birkenstocks Oh God any
crazy eye you tell the guy was dead it's
it's s laid there well this is he kind
of tough for no no no he's in [ __ ]
peanuts it khakis like I did on but I
get now you look kind of you look a
little bit silly and maybe a little you
look like a yeah and you're in your bike
helmet and you're you just look like a
giant guy on a bike huh it's not a very
flattering look oh it's just a bad idea
he could give you a little shove around
because you're in the money no you know
what happens this what happens when you
when you get together with a [ __ ] and
she's gonna get you in trouble
Chris that's the front when you're with
it oh she'll get we're not a rich [ __ ]
I'm saying I can't do anything to hurt I
show get in I don't kill you and the
horses though pretty fast yeah I you
know I'm gonna do with the horses
there's stupid nose this peach bows and
hold them hell yeah and Dan is that
right for two so you put your fingers in
their nostrils and you hold now look at
here we go hey bro yes sweet mask now
watch this you take the words new girl
and you break his neck nope just two
fingers knuckle deep in his nose and I
drop them to the ground
and I go hey hey cotton she was high o
Conte and I line all throughout and I
piss on them Oh get your camera out I
pee on them yeah and I like camera go
there's your mask it's pretty aggressive
there's your mask yeah and that crazy
though well yeah that the the yeah
society's divided into two separate
groups you gotta carry murder Hornets
and release them in their faces look
Lois I just [ __ ] them here's your
badge bend him over the rock and [ __ ]
them and took his math well that's that
would be that's my friend who's tough
guy and he goes off how about I bend you
over this rock and [ __ ] you in the ass
that garden are you gonna fight a fifty
four-year-old he goes yeah no I said I'm
gonna [ __ ] yeah I am dude you rather get
[ __ ] with a guy in the ebike in
spandex but I think what you should do
is you should say you should go hey I'll
give you a shove around that's what you
should say just say something weird
don't worry problem man well I thought I
was DS
if I make you find the horse they
weren't that's when they really sound
like bad people that's why it really got
spicy but they sound like bad people you
have a long day they're gonna have a
long day cuz there's a bunch of bikers a
bunch of hikers no masks yeah I know why
Brian yeah well we're outside we're
outside yeah it's gonna be fine now
where's your mask yeah the governor told
you dumbass to wear a mask and you're
gonna do it
and you're gonna do it why that's why I
am mom let's start with if you're gonna
do that outlaw the other things that
kill people anyway
anyway that's a tough one it's [ __ ]
Friday apparently it's not it's no
longer cute Friday it's cut Friday's
come Friday and I hope they're back
there tomorrow I kind of want to come
with you and I'm not joking no I just I
don't want to can you imagine you
imagine saying that somebody yelling me
where the [ __ ] is your math what are we
gonna do do fight fight why just bring
super soakers assume the face just
resist that's a good day I think use
laugh at them yes by the best thing
indeed I think that's a good idea
have a good day and then yeah don't
catch anthrax from your horse I don't
know more likely die being bit by the
round it's going to be is it the larger
question is that everybody seems to be
getting their information from depending
on the sources you listen to I can tell
where you stand politically right it's
it's just the way we are as human beings
I think that most of us have feelings we
have a feeling and then we go we go and
we'll we'll go and get a source of
information that compounds yes you can
support you can find online whatever
it's hard not to be that way as a human
being it's hard not to do that
it's called bias confirmation
confirmation bias and within our you're
gonna fit whatever you want yeah so
you'll go and find a source that
confirms whatever your belief system in
I'm guilty of it we go even to the
extreme yeah we're all guilty of it
we're all guilty you know it's just like
someone like pouchy is a physician and a
good person he's very cautious Rand Paul
saying the guy's a very cautious to
himself
yeah he's a and and it's very
threatening to beat a turtle and we're
all assume yeah and his
so you're going to be if you you ever
notice how doctors sometimes are super
cautious - my son bumped his head one
time I don't know if I ever told you
this and he hit his head and he was a
little boy and the doctor said if I was
my son I would yeah I would get no I
would get I would get a some cat scan
because they show sliced of the brain to
make sure he's okay and I we talked to
it how bad did he hit and cushon
specialty he hit it like rock this it
was hard but he was okay
but but then he looked in his eyes
everything's is my son I would do
because it shows slices of the brand I
was like that's a new thing and
radiation I talked to this other woman's
a hedge especially she goes I wouldn't
do talk to him scare your son exactly
hitter said life is life has its risks
but this was a very cautious man who's
also remember this if you see if you're
a traffic you're an insurance guy want
your doctor cautious by the way you want
doc dr. Carson's but if you if you or
somebody who is responsible Highway
Safety and you saw if you saw all the
the [ __ ] accidents you might be more
inclined to lower the speed limit to 40
miles an hour because you know what
would save life well you know my
father-in-law's a shift Highway Patrol
and when he drives to me you know he's
like he's got a slow down dude are you
okay I'm going 70 but he's 65 yes no my
car and he sees he cuz he sees the worst
yes and it's like anything else if you
watch certain news programs just think
that crime is everywhere right don't
think it's everywhere ring-ring calm
would you get the hose don't go to the
chat forum ring yeah you would think the
purges happy yeah you think the purchase
had it might be yeah you go on they're
like oh my god go on your go on the
computer and look at what the sex
offenders just in your neighborhoods
fanta it's dotted its dog like it's a
fun journey never let your kid out the
house are you well but yeah but you're
not saying we're not trick-or-treating
with depending on where you're standing
and the question you're asking that can
inform your reality so we all have to
kind of take a broader perspective on
everything a real look though the sex
offender so you brought that up to cost
you six nine I guess that's the reason
why they didn't want to take his money
because he's a registered that makes
sense yes that's right he supposedly
will had sex with a fifteen year old he
was in the same room when someone was
having sex and he did maybe like
Golf or something yeah he's the used a
guy in the corner with colored hair Jack
he's nice that does house again a
thousand yeah
jail dude I'll tell you usually bats a
thousand and would just struck out with
the latest movie Capone with Tom Hardy
poor track I've been know counting down
the days for this I posted the trailer
like I can't wait [ __ ] yes take my money
I paid $9.99 last night get a [ __ ]
fresh hot meal he's such a good actor
but he's so good this movie really is a
complete waste of time
and I love Tom Hardy I don't hate on me
I'm not hating on him is the premise the
whole so what is it's his last year so
Capone died of syphilis yeah and he had
syphilis for a long time because used to
be a bouncer at a brothel and slept with
all the women yeah kids if lists and how
crazy is because of his ego he didn't
want people to know he had it so he's a
guy it's not that big of a deal so he
never got it he didn't want to you don't
want to go and admit that he got STD so
he because of his ego so this I don't
even think they had a cure back then at
first say they had help they had things
that would help and then penicillin came
after World War I correct yes yes but
they had help there are things that
would definitely help and he ignored all
I didn't know Capone had that many scars
on his face yep what was that from
as a kid he got a fight but so the
movies the last year of his life when he
gets out of Alcatraz he gets out of
prison because his wife was able to
convince the government that he's you
know he's sick yes that feeling crazy
let him live his last years of his life
in Florida so they're in Palm somewhere
in Florida here's this huge mansion
there he has no money they have to sell
the statute and stuff but it this the
entire movies the the demise of Capone
and it's him talking to and this is true
would say based off him talking to his
old friends and just going crazy and
that's it and that's it did I stop shits
the bed he's pissing the bed he's just
crazy and you're like what is this [ __ ]
man I got two hours in there like what
am i doing was it critically acclaimed
with the acting or is it just like
something you don't want to see if
somebody's going crazy yeah yeah back in
stuff really that sucks it
many times I and them in the makeup it
just looks bad I love Tom Hardy's great
out five for me man great actor do we
look somewhere I heard all the time he's
one of my four lines you can't don't
wait I'm tell you don't waste your money
take your new boy there's nothing I
loved in a mafia movie I [ __ ] you said I
never loved mafia nope you got to pay
for it dude okay it's not Amazon or it's
on iTunes you can get it there it is
tough it is very tough the whole Capone
stuff I love man yes such a beast
why well you know you know so in the
height of his career if it was today he
was worth 1.5 billion dollars I'm crazy
right he ran some [ __ ] you know he's 240
pounds did you know that Capone was real
fat fat 140 pounds he short wasn't
missing any meals
I love De Niro's a component the
untouchables you ever see that movie The
Untouchables I've seen parts of my kid
he's so he's like there is violence on
in Chicago not by me not by anybody I
employ I'll tell you why the outfit was
told the outfit he's great in it you see
him you see him crying and the hot
during the Opera he plays this amazing
dichotomy it doesn't look like you know
yeah but he's so good sure you believe
he's again I think Tom Hardy but it was
a tough job because he's going crazy
it's like it's I don't know it was a
tough gig dude tough [ __ ] game
oh your boy your boy got with the San
Diego Chapter yesterday drove yesterday
morning oh that's right I heard I heard
it was a dicey road dude I heard it was
John so so Papa's been biking since the
quarantine start grew up on mount bike
daycare was a mountain bike oh okay yeah
oh okay so you got some experience they
took you on some they took you on some
[ __ ] on it bottom left winch in the
yellow bike that's uh that's a heckler
Santacruz ebike they sent it to me to
try out there that's your brother
great bike is that you that's me that
was your brother nope why would my
brother be okay I don't know brother but
I went with my boy Chris Byers who he's
been right for a while he's rep for
Santa Cruz he's a
Rep for royal bike gear those are his
trails
well these trails were built I forget
the guys name bivariate it's basically
like it'd be like Michael Jordan Michael
joining a doubles barked I like Michael
Jordan build a basketball court to make
it difficult it's possible so this guy
lives in the neighborhood across the
street but he built these trails for
competitive mountain bike ready we're
boy I'm not in that lane yet I'm not I'm
sure I'm trying to get I'm trying to
figure it out yeah those e-bikes the the
heckler Santacruz bikes ridiculous it's
ridiculous bike now they want you or
theater come with you guys our show like
you I want to say I was out of my
comfort zone yeah I'm talking you know
the there was professional riders on
there and Schumann doing these strikes
on so he's come and the one the trails
like it's long you're like 20 25 miles
and it's a lot of climbing they go down
but it's not these there's no room for
error on these because the trail is
about yay wide and there's jagged rocks
and and huge drop-offs with a jump and
there's ramp and then and then the
tricky thing is the corners are the
sharpest it is built for competition so
these so these guys King these pros can
get ready for the tour no I'm not there
yet no no but this guy never be there by
the way and that's okay yeah well that's
not my thing
no that's not what that's not about Mike
I do but this guy Chris who's a beast on
it was right so we go up in the up I'm
it I can tell I'm like all right and
there's all these trails and I go down
to pretty gnarly ghosts yeah man
because yeah and then like all right so
we're going and he's great chris is the
[ __ ] best and he jumps off does it
trick me yeah hey man we're doing tricks
now well here's the thing here's the
thing papa
here's the thing your boy crashed oh I
don't know five times or you did well
there's only one way down and I get a go
X game on this [ __ ] yeah so what I was
doing
yeah yeah I'm not used to it you got to
commit we have to commit and fly off the
edge Brian
well I'm 37 and I'm not I'm not there
mentally I'm out there I don't know so
the first one I don't commit I kind of
half-ass it when I say I didn't shoot
off I mean I went full yeah fell down
all the way down
I thought no big deal [ __ ] the entire
Santa Cruz I apologize [ __ ] the bike can
pick up your big handlebars the fact
that big quarts of scratches all over
the thing and you know rocks rocks are
not forgiving they're not jagged rocks
aren't forgiving well but this other
thing I worry about because when I do
roll into the the bushes and the vias
name their sons are out that I was
warned about so Piper's Viper I was so
scared so when I say I was stressed I
mean I'm talking white-knuckle account
thing but then but then he goes we get
done that I go of the rest trails like
this he was yeah sex was actually harder
I don't wanna say anything so we get up
and then we're going down but then I go
hey I I didn't want to side I want to
seem cool because you know and I just
went a man I usually I don't like this
competitive stuff I'm not used to man so
I get be honest I mean I did some of
those jumps I don't know what I'm doing
she goes don't you
isn't this what you do you know I don't
do this that I don't do like this
competitive stuff he goes oh [ __ ] how
long you been riding go about three
months he goes oh oh yeah no I'll help
you man so then I was like I'll follow
your lead he's like here's the thing man
I know he's scary you got to commit I
was like alright tell me what to do I'll
commitment and so by the end of it your
boy was [ __ ] I mean I'm jumping off
cliffs still crash I'm a jumping off
yeah that's not find your mom not for me
well that's where we were easy Oh Jimmy
I say I caught your boycott here what
the [ __ ] is that
oh that's not for me the trail dude
that's the trail and then you gotta just
go over that six pounds so man and I'm
on this ebike and
I would've been I would have been I
would have no would've been a delay
there so those guys are flying by me I
went but here's my thing
I got complete on my comfort zone at a
great time that bikes a [ __ ] beast
Chris is amazing he gave me all these
tips I learned so much in those three
hours yeah I learned so far you can see
how it become addictive when you can
navigate that stuff but not I need to
see that that's my mouth there you go
that's what I do
see those white trails I'll check out
where you jump okay with you well that's
why I do everyday then there's some
dicey parts sure but it's not all dice
now the turns I'm not I'm
Germany McGrath I'm not I'm not ready
for this dude but by the end of it we
got the hang of it it was a lot of fun
as girls a complete dimepiece thing just
saw her um she family
yeah now what does he do he is the owner
of a company no he's a rep for all these
companies ok he's like Heathrow when
they have like the big like world trials
and stuff he goes to those Wow
he's uh yeah he's a mechanic he does all
the stuff right great dude great dude
yeah I am in the city of chapters very
proud of now that's not San Diego
I won't there's nothing it's called oh
there we are yes a lot that's a lot is
that who is that is that you does him
that's a lot and you don't look big
there you look you look rather small
that's not forgiving train so Vipers and
sharp rocks not my thing for me not my
thing not where I want to fall well have
another seven and she does the trick so
there's that well she's grown up doing
it yeah
also she doesn't fall as hard she's also
very good yeah it was it was like such a
learning expense when I got to my car I
was so I go wait longer in my own I was
so tired though because they were so
tackling am I just my I was so tense
dude if you had perished I would have
probably had to have taken over the
thick point by Club yes and I would have
this is looking a little helmet it's
awesome so cute Wow he didn't know that
you'd only done it for three months and
really not three months right even less
than that probably maybe it's three
months is it three months well how long
would I have started the day one two
o'clock I had a bike three months every
day yeah yeah he don't there he is
so that's see I'm not I'm not there it's
just not mine I was so stressed shot -
Chris Chris Byers it's at Chris Byers 85
great bike though phenomenal bike
amazing and he in his thing was he goes
you as what you're doing is here's your
are you a control freak is you're trying
to control everything let the bike do
its job because when you're when you're
flying and going down these you gotta
let the bike do his job just hang on to
it relax
back like you gotta lower this the all
the way and let the bite the shocks all
the stuff all these things that this
bike makes the bike let it do its job
these are you're trying to control too
much you're too tense you know what I'm
doing as you're talking you're tense I'm
threatening the horse people
I still haven't forget all the horse
people I mean come tomorrow don't
everybody I'll shoot your horse right
now if you say another word I thought
I'll [ __ ] when you tell these stories
what happens is I go into I rose in my
head and then I get a snake of hatred in
my heart and then I I come up with
revenge scenario there's long believed
me unbelievable I got problems I I stop
thinking about them literally when I
went by I just thought God people are
stupid and then kept going yeah and I
was gonna be funny story in the pot at
least I got a story on the podcast
that's it man it's all an opportunity
yes so the path to live like that this
too shall powers for them yeah this too
shall pass I just find myself I will
lick their horses and their faces yep
I'm at in life and I get a lot of I'm
getting a lot of like DMS from people
going dude you're being a response do
your dams
no listen I I think masks are if I'm
around anybody old if I'm in a store if
that's we want if I'm around people have
to be close people I wear a mask I I'm
all about it I understand I I'm
respectful did you see the thing I love
my car no big guys that we're masking
cars let me see so there a lot of funny
masks out there to people with bandanas
I have a band down I feel like you're
straight bank robber
that one right there who's that wear
face masks when they're driving hey
girls Wow that's how can a hilarious and
the most accurate meme the world has
ever known is that what the [ __ ] is that
impose the same thing and go dudes that
wear masks while they're on the [ __ ]
trails it's like Jesus Christ dude Jesus
Christ what are you gonna come in
contact with
what are you watching made you that
[ __ ] scared of this look man if
you're at risk I'm gonna be respectful
of you I'm not saying not to wear a mask
if you are close to people I'm not
saying so I'm not a scientist I'm not
saying social distancing this I am a
scientist all of you guys know I am a
scientist and a doctor
for them the doctor otologist mm-hmm
bike rider that's right listen you're
not into bikes
snakes and thick dicks then my profiles
not for you snakes and thick ticks and
mom then stop following me do that thing
you posted with that preacher got it got
bitten here I went and researched that
[ __ ] he died he told me done no but he
almost died because well you got bit by
a [ __ ] rattlesnake and now he's a
little afraid of snakes he's gotta have
somebody with him he still keeps him I'm
like what is that so I forget who is it
at mixed-martial addict yeah shop
trainer true healer big boy bike club
he's all directness namesake goes dude
quit [ __ ] fling me around lying around
yeah right on the year yeah there's
blood everywhere in the Lord tells you
these are all God look at how fast that
venom works take this thing on me yeah
it didn't go well friend you know so I
again I barely see comments at
underscore thorn at our Adam underscore
thorn he goes I know them feels so he's
the guy on the king of paint he's got a
gets bit by all the bugs and snakes
oh yes yes he goes I know them feels man
great dude did he get bit by round snake
probably not he has been yes yeah you
know little guy you got bit by a snake -
what yeah not on the show so you know
just from when I when I I've looked at
this guy and now he's out of the
hospital he's okay he has a cane so
sometimes you can yeah sometimes you can
[ __ ] your sister that's what you get if
I get bit on the mountain ride my bike
that's what I [ __ ] get when you home
I've been warned people tell I see them
everywhere that's what you get dude it's
what she get you [ __ ] with snakes
that's what you get my friend while I
was I was with a couple girls my house I
had a rescue dog my dog moto was amazing
you can't put your face Oh in Mona's
face whatever happened to him when he
before I rescued him he didn't but
that's a dogs 101 she was drunk she kept
trying to kiss my dog he's hot
he's not no she yeah she was cute but I
was I wasn't getting what I wasn't
getting with either one of them
they were there we were drinking my
buddy Johnny my
self to girls that motors in my favor so
leave Madonna and moto and she kept she
was drunk and kept trying to kiss him
and moto kept biting her in the face now
listen
over and over I say her face was a
bloody mess I swear to god he kept
nipping at her nose and her face I was
like you have to get about it she kept
doing it and she was like oh it's okay
it's okay your face yeah and then and
she gave dogs yeah and I had to get rid
of my dog I placed some of the home
because he tried to do the same thing to
a six-year-old kid say you can't do that
yeah yeah of it
I had a [ __ ] I've told you this I had
a parrot Jezebel women I'm on a date
girls in my house
Jezebel just goes your finger is way too
close you know what up bring up a bring
up a scarlet macaw she was a calico
McCall is that the gray ones with the
one tails their parents this pig Baba is
he white now you get bit by that oh you
get bit by that they crack nuts and they
can take furniture apart they can take
furniture apart they will take you why
did you help take they'll take this why
label apart leave him in the channel
lesson and lesson him in the tropics
they're so smart nobody should have them
they're like chimpanzees Jezebel because
clip their room wings claws don't worry
about the claws the talons those [ __ ]
beaks can bite your finger off dude they
it bit her so badly and started crying
yes it was so deep I was like oh my god
take that [ __ ] she went home and I
never saw her again now oh no it's so
bad dude they run CH you're off deep I
shout out to 9 News govt see the lady so
9 News of my home town they would do
like Friday dumbs Denver dumb friendly
dog giveaway like they'd highlight dogs
and so this reporter is made national
news reports like and this this is here
is is Billy and he's a boxer he's a
white boxer he's two years old he's
looking for a home and she's like oh
you're so cute and the Daleks like what
are these cameras doing
I don't like oh I'm stressed she's like
oh oh
well on live TV can bring the subject
live TV
it went I'm gonna eat your top lip off
and that's a big problem
I can't watch this please now she's fine
now yeah she's flourishing I'm she looks
like Chuck's like Joaquin Phoenix
really gosh that's terrible oh she's
walking Phoenix now but about oh honey
I'm sorry about her face that's really
serious ladies I'll be here watch this I
got what you can't see it that's not
it's not that be a pit bull it's not it
yeah it's not a boxer that's a pit bull
they're looking friendly why not to get
your face out I can't watch the camera
though you have to watch it yes now
educate yourself Brian no don't turn it
off no no no no it's not bad it's not
bad it gives her a kiss it gives her a
kiss
oh that see you now even that bad okay
oh my god okay it's hard not to notice
the if we wanna make it funny
bring up the time the guy was I think
with a cop when he was try and do the
cat sell the cat bring out that she's
like and this is a fun cat that gets off
yeah and gets his not yeah at the top
it's that top one isn't it or is this it
this one very loving and then the cat
gets tangled up yep he's going Korea's
that thick Johnny Cash look we had a
wild cat come on who wants take this cat
I get a catch Pole it's like Garfield on
meth this is the guy that's a tough when
they want to be men yeah why would you
put your legs with paint and then look
we're buds trying to sell this cat
oh my god hey behind you blood for Brian
this is only building the dog story here
nice cat here available come on KJ
return find you home I can't thank you
pinky a pinky Garfield son
cats are fairly athletic super athletic
watch this though that goes you know
what dude you know what thick Johnny
Cash watch this time we caught crop you
nuts that's kind of hurt
hey no please play this the title is
YouTube videos painful it's a good thing
this is the film Shriver you be costing
a fortune non-professional trees much
too close to buildings sidewalks trunks
utility lines he bites his dick both of
that eye looks like a friendly dog
decrease their value of now it's just a
comedy thing the system of that tree
will be establishing itself and
therefore it doesn't have to worry about
Lee the best is when people have those
dogs on the new student the dog state
takes big [ __ ] in the middle of an
interview that [ __ ] that dog took a big
chunk out of her lip yeah I mean she's a
local hero now you cannot do that with a
[ __ ] pit bull or Dora keep your face
away with any dogs at the lab mostly
she's talking she was busy you don't do
really [ __ ] her for the Dogo Argentino
nearly [ __ ] us I don't pay I don't pet
him I know I've had on my own pit bulls
I have two men
I don't pet him good loose I don't know
your dog so I mother like good like
felon yeah mobility that system no no
you can't trust them I love I love them
so much I just don't they're too
powerful
Kaylin what's your kids oh no no
Shepherds any of those dogs I love I
love all those dogs I want those I own
them but they're they have to be my dog
liability I don't know your dog I don't
know your dog are too powerful too
dangerous too scary awful and same thing
with a [ __ ] Jaguar a foot not a
cheetah a Jaguar Jaguar a [ __ ] lion
and a tiger well I don't have those
baboon she ballsy no these
come on a dragon well I tell you the
great Trevor Whitman who's one of the
greatest coaches to ever coach and mix
martial arts has something like eleven
world champions isn't he just engaged
yeah he's just engages my coach Shane
Carwin Nate Marquardt GSP he's helped
endless you know Rose nominees all
everybody he his wife goes hey let's get
one of those cool African what are the
[ __ ] you know those cats you're the
African yeah a ceremony a servicer is
let's get one of those yeah Trevor goes
I don't want them around my daughter
yeah and she goes no he'll be cool what
we'll do is we'll leave them in the
basement
well that another normal cat the normal
cat that's exactly what they had yeah so
they had in their basement right yes I
know if somebody has two of those yep
check this story out so they had a basic
kitten goes well I smell this other cat
because that cats going in the basement
so the little cat goes I'm gonna go down
there little cat goes down there well
the doors closed so little cats putting
its paws this perhaps like oh what the
[ __ ] is this playing playing playing
that cat goes I don't like the way your
Paul's look Shashank
ate its paws
Oh nope just kind of shank ripped them
off yeah that's a cerebral and you know
I will get rid of it after that when you
put a Jaguar in a leopard or whatever
any even two Jaguars
like this they're two Jaguars in a zoo
and they're separated by a steel thing
any other case they [ __ ] kind they
yell at each other through the thing
true trevor Whitman's made a lot of
smart decisions that was a bad one he's
fighting to hate me to tell this story
but I don't want Tom uh Trev that's a
bad it's a bad [ __ ] decision but they
are beautiful and they're not so I know
but they're not I know I know somebody
who has a couple why she sleeps with
them I guess they're kind of like you
got a frickin look at that thing that
thing is a [ __ ]
oh you're sleeping next to a bobcat yeah
get a bobcat yeah gorgeous though I kind
of want one but I'll never have Trevor's
knocking like that story how about
because Ben Rothwell
I fought Ben Rothwell years ago years
ago how about yeah yeah I know if he
still does any more than how that that
ends well yeah cuz he's super
responsible said I don't think that's a
serval is it that's a spotted cat
nope no no that's an African one he's
talked about it okay
yeah that's not your normal cat let's
not yeah okay I can't tell her no it's
one of those dangerous cats yeah
but ben roethlisberger Saturday or on
Wednesday night you watch the fights no
I watch the fights I didn't watch
Rothwell fight when you don't watch
fights yeah I did Wednesday night I
didn't see the fights on Wednesday I
didn't watch the Saturday I watched nope
fights on Wednesday do a lot of fights
yep who else fought OSP Ross Rothwell
fought osp's ass a hot so thick
how'd he do he just he just looked like
he was like I'm gonna go to heavy I'm
not trained has he been injured her out
for a while what happened you just
wanted to get a heavyweight hey don't
brothel end up women a split decision
nobody really won it was a decent fight
he lost so you didn't see Anthony Smith
Glover Teixeira I did not oh my was that
the show's thrown in the towel
oh no Denny Smith got [ __ ] by go over
bad I would never have called that bad
no a-league over was the underdog I know
this is great how about so clovers just
beating the piss on the fees on top of
him hitting them and you seen him as you
said he's a very good wrestler you said
Glover Teixeira sand maybe Sea World
Champion yeah yeah I mean phenomenal
well you think the jujitsu because he's
Brazilian you don't think wrestling he's
getting everything yeah but he tough as
nails so he's literally beaten he's the
nice guy in the world yeah sure I've
Anthony Smith and he was I'm sorry this
is what's great about Muhammad crowd
he's punching us I'm sorry it's part of
the job and as he's hitting that Smith
is out of it and he goes you think
they're about to stop and Smith goes
what and he goes I'm sorry it's part of
the job man I'm sorry
cuz he's such a nice guy and Anthony
Smith goes it is what it is man this is
you can hear it oh do I gotta see that
can't we yeah why not
I'm a junkie probably shut it [ __ ] yeah
yeah Dean Smith goes it is what it is
man Anthony Smith's a bad mother and how
about how about how about end of the
fourth round
did your high fight no well that's their
picture that we're and end of the foot
just please don't you write in fight but
when Anthony Smith went to his corner in
the-- Smith is as tough as they come
toughest guy in the world but still won
the John Jones fight off a DQ didn't
want to do it I mean yeah killer
so he goes like this corn and goes my
teeth are falling
oh [ __ ] that wasn't I took that as
Anthony Smith way going hey dude uh
we're not we're not about to fight my
teeth are falling out corners like a
cool story dude get the [ __ ] back out
there
my teeth are falling teeth are falling
out it's - I think he's such a great
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] up you got to stop
the fight just fight another day I mean
also tell her I'm below the belt but you
see John's tweet savage no because
you're not the Smith house they had a
robber
and he beat the SH out of the robbery
yes the burglar yeah John Jones tweeted
and deleted I bet you globe tech Sarah
what I got that TV fine man oh [ __ ] it's
part of my embrace the villain here you
go Sheriff see he's giving up everybody
I want if I'm sorry it's part of the job
is huh I'm sorry it's part of the
juggies it is what it is he's getting
the globus on top just perform edits
beat his brains in can i he's at that
press conference that picture of him
does not look good man Anthony hate I
hate when they take punishment Orlovsky
wanna get it and do it for God have
forever
how long is Orlovsky bundu I'll tell you
doing it for real he wasn't doing it for
20 years dude oh yeah I mean in the UFC
maybe for 15 no because you went you
went to world sir yeah yeah but I mean
while Anthony just first fight in the
UFC was probably 15 years ago yeah when
him and uh Jim silver fighting each
other every other week oh man I hate
that his teeth come on dude what they
said it was his veneers if that makes
any difference at all I don't know but
if I'm 1/4 my knockout dozen his teeth
are falling out miss not like I think
this so big - man he's such a good
fighter yeah yes Global tech chure
quietly ran off for straight as baby
force age of 40
what is 40 who did he beat the who's the
last guy he beat I think Smith people
over - no no [ __ ] oh don't bring it
up I'll remember it he beat Gustafson
that's [ __ ] nuts no no he beat Rashad
oh gosh don't beat cuffs and
ow clover Teixeira hold on anthe Smith's
last win was Vince I don't know I know
that I saw that fight I'm talking about
clover love it you said clovers one for
is one for straight yeah who else uh
Anthony Smith all right Frye loves a
monster he beat him split decision Wow
monster and this guy's the one that
played possum number ten he was knocked
out yep amazing dude decent night of
fights not as good as Saturday - 49 this
Saturday doing fight companion what's
how are we doing that card starts that's
it main card stretch that's it all right
decent card it's free fight night I'm
excited excited
we can't wait over him Walt Harris your
main event Claudia get deja the dine
peace oh boy over him another one
fighting since 1970 1817 doing the damn
thing since 1917 yeah barbozza Danny are
you whose hands were hill I'm seeing her
I owe you she's on Rogen's podcasting
yeah she's great
this is a go fight there that's a great
song it on what that air ganders jock
goes up ridiculous like fun fights
barbozza kinda feelings great fighters
keep up with yeah you should I keep up
with a little bit I'm sorry I washed
every fighting Saturday yeah it was a
big paper yeah this one was free on TV
it's important know what if it's old
with knots that's me in Florida yeah all
the same place pro-sports going to
Florida to very impressed
yeah pro sports you can start open up
NFL not changing anything hmm
and if I'm playing without it without
people in this now they some they think
there's me fans to really not but just
not full capacity yeah II think give me
some some people sitting every others
chair or something like that I don't
know I don't know that's what they're
talking about though it's great man it's
the bloodline of America you and I are
kind of I think in some ways the first
comics to do a show like a legit show
yeah I think we might be the first
comics pioneers yeah we both die
hilarious yeah hilarious I dunno I know
a certain actor Altay who is very famous
who thought this whole co19 thing was a
conspiracy and then he got sick the
hospital is and he was like this [ __ ] is
real you don't want it it's doesn't that
fake no it's there it's real Cole buds
19 is real and it's very dangerous for
some people especially that's be on the
new study came out with you furro beasts
what does it obese people yeah it's no
joke you still got to be very careful
how do you like the Jamison it's nice
it's really good definitely about him
Johnnie Walker yeah Johnny Johnny Walker
Johnny Walker Johnny Walker you know uh
what's the big one the big Japan whiskey
the Joshua the one that she is the one
I've messed with like you mean Nika nope
nope not the biggest one
satori-san Tori sense a Tori bought out
Jay I think they own James good I think
they don't Jack Daniels they took over
them I don't know why but for me I felt
I found that I liked Japanese whiskey
and I don't know if that's in my head or
if it's just a certain taste if it's a
high-end Japanese with I don't think
there's anything better
ah there you go as far as whistle right
so I stay on whiskey yeah as far as
American whiskey goes I love Buffalo
Trace Buffalo Trace Blanton's
yeah I like I've been feels overrated oh
when we go to Houston with my boy
whiskey Pete yeah you tell me you and
Brian come on they were doing the show -
I said we're come on the show yep I'm
excited and he goes in I said
actually bring your surplus of that
Civil War whiskey so Brian can try it
well I told I told Jacob I said let's
let's schedule that show a little bit
closer to dinner time so we can you know
well you can't do that okay
because drinks let's get one oh it is oh
I didn't know that
oops sorry sorry whiskey Pete before the
show no I don't do that no no I'm saying
what time are we gonna do the show on
Friday like twelve all right and we
drink some whiskey there yeah you don't
get hammered yeah tasty little tasting
yeah
were you worried our restaurants open in
Houston your breast is Dinan yes is
opening up my family were there said
that beautiful so it was so funny sup
some fans like shop good Sam Houston's
up we're not [ __ ] open and somewhat
some guy said hold my beer and goes I'm
at Chili's right now screenshot a
picture dude you would have thought they
were doing a kanye west easy drop it was
so packed so bad people on top of each
other only it's gonna full rack of ribs
this is where it's gonna be the fall
will tell what their cases caseloads
look like in florida and all these
places gonna be interesting to see no we
can feed them yeah you look at it right
now that's where the [ __ ] is your mask
how crazy
still thinking about that can't do that
to me because what happens is it's in
your head now I going to I'm gonna cook
this off it starts to fester oh that's
Brennan I'm that way he's that way too
but I'm I'm not like no I'm not really
that way not something not with
confrontation if we have a business
thing he'll go I think we're getting
[ __ ] here and he'll just you're just
tells me that actually I've seen you
before
and then I I go ah what I trust you what
am I getting fat and then I sleep on
another thong and then I'm I get I have
an anger problem I actually do when I
get angry right away you text right away
you're like well let me just yeah you
have a bet you bet anger yeah when I get
angry it's it's it's it's a problem yeah
brother worse yeah out of all my friends
angers you yeah you see Jay Jay if it's
a big deal he'll fly off the hinges yeah
but you I'll probably start punching way
before someone like you for you know
yeah even those people could have said
anything they wanted now if it's in
it's an injustice I get a little I get I
don't know something happens to me
people saw you almost getting a fight
outside here madam Alka oh yeah they're
like we've never seen Bryan like this
before
yeah yeah I was gonna I was gonna kill
the guy was that a bomb right yeah he
was but he's young and he remembers you
like a [ __ ] thing we'll be like you
have no money I made all the right
choices I'm gonna set you on fire
Bobo and then he yelled uh it's just cuz
your dad and you were like I'm gonna set
you on fire yeah I said don't set my
fire yep and I said where's your mat
with your [ __ ] mask can i trample
them with my horse I said they've
trampled you with their work yeah horse
was so big yeah this was giant that's
1,200 pounds of muscle well you sure
says I'm hungry I'm gonna I'm gonna find
where where your horse is and I'm gonna
butcher it um yeah that guy that guy
almost got punched that guy I was like I
I was measuring distance and I was gonna
have enough I can't remember last time
I've even been close to punching him
well he came at the he came out this
dude guys I can't think all that when
there's that time that old lady tried
stealing my kid I told her I'd snap her
neck
that'll cause that's my time you you're
you're by brought a joke about this tape
I mean I thought I want ma'am you touch
that kid I'm gonna spike you in for it
all these people you were watching and
filming I'm gonna spike down your
[ __ ] head yes if you try and touch my
kid shun not like oh like Lily steal my
kid some crazy [ __ ] I'll come at all
I'm after snappy nut I'm just um yeah
yeah yeah sometimes you cut a person's
hitches be crazy bro you're not gonna
get our shooting on today we'll shoot
some guns yeah but you I don't do the
whole thing just give me there you know
I don't add I kinda do have to do that
all right yeah oh we do we have to do
that no safety first we'll figure it out
no safety get I don't want to do the
whole I'm not just get out let's get our
arsenal ready yeah I don't do whole I
need tons of animal ammo I'm buying that
ar-15 okay doesn't keep me all right
we're starting we're starting our we're
building our fort okay we are
Jim we got to bring you mean cat we want
to go you do right Ashley all right
today we can't go today cuz oh they
already know whatever we're now set it
up I'll set it up cool yeah that is my
treat
thank you I'll find the time just tell
me what would give me times that are
good I will take you out to Terran
tactical whatever whenever I'm not
working
Cheney posted I did I couldn't listen to
it because I saw it too late at night
and I won't wake up anybody what's the
video post are you singing and you guys
won't like this is he gay I liked it as
I watched I was just like a funny post
cuz I thought your post is funny -
Brian's was Lions this steroid well I
said that that that wasn't what I was
doing is making a point can saving lives
in other words an out-of-shape
I hope people know I wasn't serious
about putting people in jail for being
fat what I was saying is that if you use
the criteria the criteria have used
criteria saving lives diabetes kills
almost 80,000 Americans you put them in
jail yeah I'm joking Bill Cassidy you
can you can you can take things to it if
that's your criteria for everything you
can you can justify any kind of behavior
and I hope that wasn't lost if it's a
joke it's a Jewish de origen let me find
it real quick no it's right there so
I'll just fast-forward the part that I
thought was funny no let me see the
whole thing
it's the whaha one it's five minutes
dude and we own the own this footage we
and the fans can see it all right cats
in it - you guys are all in it oh really
yeah I've got in my music video I like
to see my royalties you like the slower
gems
I love Michael Bolton like a bone
pathway no no no
I could hardly believe it when I heard
the news take
- come and get it straight from you
[Music]
Hardaway wave centromere tell me about
tell me about the planche thinking
Oh
tell me one more thing before I come
that's not easy
[Music]
that is not easy
[Music]
when
Wow so I'll just fast forward that's
been very good thank you I'm sorry
yeah you didn't miss a [ __ ] me out Ryan
in there that's not-- perfect
that's [ __ ] a real isn't that a
really hard song to sing it's motif it's
tough on you physically yes
[Music]
you would like to shut out Michael
Bolton he's no he's amazing yes people
should Michael Ball how they love it why
meanwhile that guy's talented
[Music]
[Music]
that's still funny
so that was it that's really good that's
very [ __ ] you that's really funny
you gotta let these hoes know Chen no
yeah how's your girl been around Tim has
she been hanging out yeah every weekend
you go to her house or she goes she
lives in what area Orange County
yeah easy drive that's lucky bad
especially right now yeah yeah dude I
got two outside of sandy I'm not saying
anything at all wherever I was on those
crazy tracks about hour-and-a-half
driving hard that's the one thing that's
gonna suck about my opens up I'm so used
to it now it's so easy it's so nice yeah
traffic's already building up now it's
getting there yeah it's getting better
just trying to be very easygoing about
all of it don't tell me those stories
anymore hey man all right mr. Vasquez
ties short short short but sweet podcast
today mm-hmm
short for sweet first one yeah okay this
is sick so nuts
um statistics have shown that if Amazon
stays on the same trajectory that it's
on right now
by 2026 Jeff Bezos is set to be the
first trillionaire in the world how many
billions is that anyone a thousand
billion a thousand billion that's one
thousand one thousand billion dollars
it's so hard to fathom how much money
that is it's insane it's insane
mmm it's it's I mean all right you'd be
the first trillionaire in the world yeah
I can't believe Geddy danger - Trillian
can I have a like can you do very hot
thirty degrees again yeah I have two
trillion bro
thirty-three come on it's a ton of money
thirty three times a thousand that's
thirty three thousand so because because
of a billion seconds is thirty three
years a billion seconds that's a
thousand bill
yeah what's that comparison it was
amazing 3,000 years really a million set
a billion seconds 1 billion seconds is
about 33 years and then 1 million is
like so a trillion seconds is 33,000
years that's how much money he has truly
in seconds $70 just 34% a year I'm sorry
I'm sorry
Gru's 34% every year the last five years
it's well what what he from what I've
heard and a guy who wrote a bacillus
sniper I yeah but the guy said he's he's
very very intent on creating charities
and doing something very good with that
money like really good with that money
he's not gonna keep it all yeah what are
you gonna true you could never spend
what do you know I mean look at that
reason so a million a million seconds
there's only about 11 days yeah 11 days
in a billion seconds is 32 years that's
how that's what I'm that's the
difference between
now hold on and then take a billion it's
a thousand billion I have a thousand
billion dollars what the [ __ ] are you
talking about how much money do you have
I have a thousand million dollars that's
nuts but by 2026 what do you do
you liam comes with huge responsibility
you have to make the world a better
place you got to figure out it and
everyone wants a piece of something well
yeah I mean
so as of Honk's role as a Thursday
morning he was worth 143 billion
compared to last year he's worth 28
billion that's it
huge I guess it becomes exponential
everybody needs it it's the some guy
puts Jeff Bezos about to become the
world's first driller while we're about
to enter a depression Djoser goes this
is a bad place that's just sick
and unprecedented thirty million
Americans have unemployment numbers
still grown but cowan a few guys making
em a trillionaire I mean well he will
he's got to figure out here Jeff Bezos
well sometime in the near future have
more money than the Netherlands totally
normal nothing out
here okay come up with em son though hey
you can hate on the guy but he came up
with a product here a product that
changed the world
oh god you'd love that if only she had a
giant [ __ ] out the front I mean as if
maybe she does get you oh that's big
oh we have to go through a million he's
a good guy he's from mizuno that thing
is just click big but she's huge
clickbait gets bright yep click on that
please George George on some oh she's
not sure yeah six-foot-two we're just
all not crazy though I don't should be
on the list Peter Carr like it's the
tallest soccer player oh my my joy of
course is old [ __ ] nothing will find
that girl
you got our barred by Fedor I mean he
was awful
he was not a good fighter yeah he's bad
he's just big Stefan's truth still doing
it I remember when you were fighting and
he was fighting and we were sitting
there and talking I go what how would
you how would you fight him in I've
never seen this you know I'd knock him
out how about us I supposed to fight him
and we had the deal signed and then two
days later and I ran it's him it's with
Trevor Whitman like this you'd hold him
realize no so anyways so he's home it's
like Isis truce so tall Anderson puts on
moments like this oops
and then that you hate Dana's on the
phone and what do dan white´s on the
fine what's up because I got cro cop oh
and that's when I get a croak out I mean
Struve never [ __ ] the tree Matt's at
seven alright pretty normal what does he
do
no idea he's a model okay it's just
beautiful
he's a personal trainer
you've gone through these are all our
matters
this is all that matters these have
bigger Amazon naive six eight she this
proportional rescission model all right
that's all good so I think it'd be tough
to be that big giant was news [ __ ]
he's doing miserable look at how big us
Milan for he was miserable of course he
was still when he's flying the pain he
was in the three drinks Aloha really
yeah I'm eight feet tall was doing body
shield like that eight feet no eight
feet that says Argentinian that's tough
I think you both of course that's the
way your heart can't take it there you
go right whoa first beam all fed oh well
that's a big girl
damn that's not necessary well for her
it is what seven six what I wonder I was
think about was a guy taco came to like
Africa like Miss Sudan and stuff and saw
people that tall Randy Johnson old
school yeah he's a big fella I bet you
won't have that girl or she's the very
last one yeah yeah the reason everybody
clicked on it wait they had Michael
Phelps on those six floor yeah it
doesn't matter guys no no we've gone
down this far
whoa who's that supposed to be here no
she's like you talk I'm out six four
girl got where's this big [ __ ] that we
clicked on this for Brenda I bet you see
I don't know we're already down this
[ __ ] path dude
alright good how we have to we have to
follow through keep going six three
that's a tall gal boy what if she isn't
even on this list I'm [ __ ] pissed
yeah we just were here till tomorrow
we're not stopping how many big athletes
are there it's like I'm an a fraud
crickets pretty much seven one
well that big hairy cheese rushing cat
how big is he oh you son but Brittney
Griner six nine which is huge for a girl
yeah well for anyone actually mmm right
we might be stuck here for an hour
it's just every stoppers in the world
that means I can't do this anymore
Brennan now let's go to more all right
Oh
one two all right one more just one odd
blissful 4:45 throwing darts look at the
size of his I can't forearm right it's
just not been missing any meals oh my
god there's we can't we can't find this
maybe one more and that's it that's it
after this after eight curry I'm [ __ ]
he's putting my foot down right after
this [ __ ] guy right after this guy
that's right that's it [ __ ] one more
I can do live yeah [ __ ] all right you
know maybe one more just to be safe last
one to be safe one more there we go home
75 they're both in I know why is this
guy oh it's Brian China or something
yeah what all right just one last one I
guess now you're doing it no cuz that
was my new bull weird you know him well
his sons in it I never mind it's not
gonna work six nine impossibly tall the
next to the rock oh my god alright next
one yeah okay
do you guys know what only fans is no
sure do so only fans is an app where you
can pay a monthly subscription to see
photos and videos that people post up
and a lot of people will use this to
post up either like nude or like sexy
photos of themselves through a paywall
yeah and this woman she has an only fans
account and she's saying that her
subscribers have gone down because of
kovin 19 and that because she has her
subscriber count going down she's not
making as much money she can't pay her
rent so she went on tik-tok to start
crying about how she's losing
and then you start dancing it's scary
when you have no I have no other way to
make a living no she's a sugar daddy I
think you're perfect for the job this is
this is actually she's a little crazy
and all that but this is actually very
real for a lot of people yeah those
Instagram models in these to watch him I
watched Garcetti smiling I watched them
smiling on Anderson Cooper and talking
about how we're moving and you can do
curbside pick them and I'm like hey dude
it's not funny it's not funny for most
people there are a lot of people living
alone who have no options what are you
doing for them what are you doing for
them the this is very serious for a lot
of people they they don't have money for
[ __ ] you know and they don't care
they just want to get Trump out so bad
whatever it yes at any expense and this
is in your system this is going on all
the time yeah I feel bad for it I wish
we'd help her out I'm just saying you
can extrapolate this where there are
families and [ __ ] like that or it I feel
so terrible well wait a minute let me
see what's going on there
121,000 I mean I want to help people out
with their rent her only fans a
subscription she needs some help
she's in England yeah that's a shame
look I'm almost real
what about this instead of a boyfriend
come on that guy's cool yes super cool
but at least she's honest you know I'm a
[ __ ] that's hot
can he not make money though all right
what's the first thing about her
boyfriend I'm sure it's I don't know
dude I think I'm catching a cold
oh wait it's a little thick [ __ ] I'm
like gay okay I get that
hmm yeah I don't know I'm a fan of the
effort I'm a fan over as well you know
postpartum it's top-heavy
it's tough way to make money man it's
tough to make a living when everything
is shut down and I see again I see the
mayor you know with a smug look on his
face smiling man I don't know man yeah
she's not very veiny boobs if she had a
kid sometimes that'll happen when you're
breastfeeding mm-hmm nothing wrong with
it though nope all right what else yep
just here okay so the funniest thing
ever I haven't seen it awful yeah it's
just a silly video of a drunk pig
because it got into fermented corn yeah
a bunch of fermented corn that was
supposed to be used for moonshine
hilarious
I sent this assassin to Lee and I was
like this is you guys during Kovac too
much corn
now this is a fat pig okay they're all
[ __ ] up just that one why just that
one that's the only one who got into the
fermented corn hey see fart
what are you messed up girl never seen a
damn Pig oh he's all she's all [ __ ] up
pig flip that's the tough part about
eating bacon I think they're so adorable
to think about that - yeah it's weird
yeah man and I love I [ __ ] love pork
might be my favorite meat pork really
really or you don't like bacon and stuff
that's all right yeah I like my favorite
by far I like pork chops pork chops are
great I love y'all like it's so much hmm
oh you know I do I like the ribs I'll
eat the ribs I like prunes
I do understand I get I get a vegan I
get a vegetarian I get it I get it yeah
do it I get it you do it like people
like I can't eat an animal I understand
yeah I respect like understand I just
can't do it
yeah but I don't have to eat their faces
I wish I could be that way do it you
could do it for your people and I am
what you could do if you want though you
know no I can't you don't think so no I
discipline how about I show you the
animal you eating like a picture of him
really well if you if you live on a farm
you you got attached to your animals
you've not my little cousin she took
care of these little pigs since they
were little baby little piglets she
loves them and everything but she had no
problem when it was time to kill him and
then eat him
yeah so I ate the bacon to that deer
yeah was he good it's really good it's
it's so weird seeing her taking care of
man and how'd she kill him well she took
it to the place to get killed
well that says that says all this time
that's as old as time you got to eat I
mean as long as you didn't waste any
part of them yeah it's fine
yeah there's also postmates snow though
yeah it's like one time Logan on the
podcast thing I was like I just thought
it was super funny this is plays eat
your heart out it's this girl has a good
voice really good he's not bad control
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
goes back to it he sounds good he's so
bored support lay in love with this cool
tattoo on his wrist very good all right
do you know these players by chance the
one I do the Andre Baker and quit and
Dunbar what [ __ ] were they doing man so
the the New York Giants and I think the
Seahawks or something but either way so
they were Adams on traffic I think to a
19 first-round draft pick for the giant
what are you waiting corner so they're
at a party and suddenly they got an
argument during that party and then they
pulled guns out or this is their accused
of one of them's pulled a gun out and
then they ended up robbing the people at
the party for really expensive watches
and some other stuff and they took off
and
borghini and mercedes-benz in a BMW that
was their getaway card they said this
was also most likely planned because
everything was set up perfectly
apparently they were gambling before
these two guys and lost 70 grand so this
is their way to sort of get it back so
it sounds like they're making a lot of
good choices here I mean so weird
they're NFL freaking stars but I guess
if you get caught up in gambling you
could lose money like that but I mean
you're the starting corner fan out is
you're robbing people so they're accused
the [ __ ] so they have a warrant out
for their arrest but they haven't been
arrested yet as a Vaastu before we're
thinking for well thank you can you get
III you'd have to be actually truly dumb
and they're very young to things like 22
or something yeah but you still have to
be very know that is incredibly they
pulled out guns you're known you're a
public figure and you think you're gonna
get away with it or what what is it that
you think you're gonna do here
it's so stupid hard to fathom it's
shocking okay all right job guys
let's look at some good ones you gotta
be more than that story gotta be right
let me illustrate what you do well
here's a quick one just sort of Emily
related could be was dad he went under
heart surgery and it was in a coma for a
loss so it wasn't looking good he had
pneumonia too but it turns out he might
be like he's speaking again he is up and
he might be okay after this but Conor
McGregor who's notoriously hardcore on
could be sent out you know this really
nice message praying for the recovery of
Kabir's father a man responsible for
more world champions across multiple
fighting disciplines than we even know a
true martial genius very saddened upon
hearing the news tonight praying for
khabib and his family wow it's horrible
right yeah thank God he's okay
alright so remember that Pentagon
released the UFO videos there's two
pilots or whatever and then so this
happened I forgot how many months back
but it happened a few months back and
then they read they said they release it
again right and then now they're saying
that they believe it to be drones
actual drones yeah but they don't know
if they're you know who's Manning the
drones but they believe it might be from
China
trying to get ya information so then I
not necessarily real UFOs yeah but drawn
together and they're five feet five you
wide ones a lot bigger
they say it's Russia or China they
believe that's what they think when I
was in that Afghanistan I would watch
these drones take off the killer drones
so weird to watch them just we need to
be like is anybody in that movies
[ __ ] they look like aliens they do
small control they were there to do some
killing you just see the moment you see
them on a tarmac just sitting there like
they look like that have this big
[ __ ] hood you really yeah you'd be
like [ __ ] it's gone off to do something
and there's not much other stuff that
guy that cop they talked about before
who got fired yeah he's doing pretty
well now good that's his a GoFundMe now
how's that over $400,000 for Wow yeah
that's does he make you be enough cop
not he said he didn't expect this much
money and he's gonna try to do something
good with it well awesome
set yourself up to get sick yourself
then you got three kids mm-hmm that's
cool I think that's pretty much it
oh I don't think you guys care about
this but head of the class was very
famous back in there anything it was 80s
hmm they're done reboot won't remember
it neither do i Robins in it I think he
showed up later or maybe not enough
where do you see Freddy minute now that
I know he's way too young for this one
so but that's Robin Givens right there
what is she at all know how I didn't
watch it the original sure [ __ ]
watching the bootleg reboot Robin Givens
still looking good mm-hmm 2019 she was
on what's that watch what happens live
mm-hmm she married now oh she might have
gotten some money from Mike Tyson how
much she got him let me see this real
quick cuz she's smart woman pretty huh
late 20s she's rocking 20 19 inches
Riverdale
I was a big hit right
mmm she's good-looking woman man they
had it on there nowhere
[Music]
ten million yeah yeah oh that's a
divorce settlement staying that she
didn't receive a dime
mmm interesting hmm good all right well
it looks pretty hot yes she does
well I mean yeah doing the damn thing
yep all right
and I'm Robin Givens short sweet buddy
short sweet shout-out to everybody out
there including including the horseman
more about love about love you should
see on the track so the best thing to do
is this yeah thank you for thank you for
watching out for me I love you I love
you I'll be so funny
if you have way better I probably burn
optimum Jimmy Burke was a master at that
Jimmy Burke who thought he'd go you're
right you're absolutely right and I love
you I love you and you look amazing
today here just [ __ ] be mad
thank God goes oh he pays Congress it's
si Jimmy goes hey guys your smart ass
because I am I am a smart ass I am a pig
smart ass I have a big smartest as well
and I still love you just picturing him
saying that it's all the best the best
I'll kick your ass your titties her tits
are getting off it quit calling me her
her tits are all [ __ ] bunched up you
got to tighten your bra up and stuff I
don't want to fight her yeah kill him of
kindness shut the [ __ ] up so I'll call
me harm no I gotten hilarious nobody
better well I'll just pray just pass
them tomorrow any problem now you're
calling I'm going but I'm not gonna do
anything
no you could drive up there I I have my
kids tomorrow
it's me tough free to go I'll keep you
posted maybe I'll film it may I put on
Instagram please please just send it to
me
maybe I well yeah send it to me
we're at chosen Houston ironic shows to
Houston right yeah if you could tell me
about tickets we're gonna add some shows
Diamond spoken end of the month end of
June so I spoke in I'm in all up in
spoken and then tablets I'm not in
Phoenix I'm gonna take that off this do
you do but I mean I know spoke in and
then we're adding I don't know if
tickets are available yet go to wise
guys in Salt Lake City
July 16 17th and 18th I'm in wise guys
in Salt Lake City and I will also be the
first thick boys bike club meeting as
well in Salt Lake City but my babeh get
your thing boy bike club merch right now
thick boy calm t5k calm Brian I will see
them in Houston though dude yeah Allen
shows I'm gonna come too so we come to
Salt Lake and spoke in I wouldn't mind
I'm coming okay all right
I'd like to come so late because I got
my family there yeah it's in us we're
that they are in Park City
yeah that's were the good writings as
porosity let's do it up all right
tik-tok time for tickets think boy that
time for merch all right this fine kid
we're out